as we get closer and closer to the
November election I've been talking
about how much of Donald Trump's
behavior over the next three months is
going to be coming of a place of
desperation from a place of desperation
out of a sense of desperation and David
shipler wrote a really interesting
article yesterday in Washington Monthly
called beware of a cornered trump which
really builds on this idea that you and
I have been talking about for a while
that if Donald Trump's polling continues
to be bad and remember he's pretending
like he doesn't believe the polling but
his actions speak otherwise replacing
his campaign manager and all of the you
know restarting coronavirus briefings
all wearing a mask all the things that
he's doing if his polling doesn't
improve it doesn't have to necessarily
get worse but just if it doesn't improve
we would expect based on everything we
know about Donald Trump that he would go
even more in the directions that we have
seen him tend to directions of
corruption and depravity and
authoritarian tendencies which will
likely become even more severe in case
in point we're really already seeing
that over the last couple of weeks the
deployment of camouflage troops with no
badges to Portland Oregon where they are
throwing people into unmarked vans and
claiming that they're going to expand to
more cities even as soon as this week
and we'll see if that happens we're
seeing the authoritarianism and really
the desperation and the disregard for
human life manifest in the demand from
Trump that schools just open in the fall
health considerations be damned
just get open we are seeing Donald
Trump's desperation to prevent people
from voting against him manifest in his
unhinged opposition to vote by mail
which in practice this year just means
expand absentee ballots through the
process we already have to whoever wants
it just virulent opposition to that on
completely false and bogus grounds and
as David shipler says in this article
which we're going to link to and I
encourage you to read and I like this
term Trump has no moral brakes there's
nothing there where morality would pump
the
rakes for him david shipler goes on to
say his values are those of a mafia boss
who rewards and punishes those who
protect or oppose him who protect for
opposing him punishes those who protect
or oppose him now to be thorough david
shipler also mentions our fear could be
wrong maybe Trump won't go completely
off the rails for example maybe Trump
won't send these armed paramilitaries
that are now being floated in places
like Portland maybe Trump won't send
them to monitor polling places to
intimidate voters in November we're
worried that he's going to do that but
maybe he won't do it maybe our fear is
overblown and we hope that it's
overblown in the sense that Trump could
be too incompetent or unable to think
far enough ahead to actually do the
horrible things that he would have no
moral problem doing if Trump stops short
of what we fear he would do it would be
not because of a moral awakening but
because he forgets or is incompetent or
isn't able unable to get something done
but there is this constant feedback loop
or vicious cycle
Trump's ignorance and delusions of
grandeur and narcissism reinforce his
most dangerous impulses which when he
does and sees that he gets a reaction
reinforces his narcissism and delusions
of grandeur and vixa victimhood
mentality that no one's been treated as
poorly as him you combine this with this
silver spoon upbringing and what appears
to be probably some personality
disorders based on the mental health
professionals we've spoken to there is
no check on Trump's behavior anywhere
and in fact when we hear that Trump had
an idea and didn't carry it out it
typically is because either a he gets
distracted by something else or be a
group of people in his in his
administration are able to talk him out
of it or prevent him from doing it and
then he moves on to something else it
comes down to what can he get away with
what can the people around him stop him
from doing and it also shouldn't be
ignored that the administration is in
itself a threat by virtue of its mere
existence this is an administration
has been a threat to the economy it's
been a threat to international relations
and our alliances with other countries
the administration obviously in what
we're seeing with coronavirus has been
an existential threat to public health
there continues to be a shockingly large
percentage of Americans though that
still support the President and still
support this administration despite
everything that's going on right now and
that is sort of part two of how a
desperate Trump becomes a dangerous
Trump some portion of Trump supporters
and I don't know what the number is but
I fear that it's a larger percentage
than we want to admit some portion of
Trump supporters are willing to do
violence like real world violence if
that's what Donald Trump suggests or
implies or in any way signals may be
appropriate and so when Donald Trump
said to Chris Wallace on Sunday when
asked can you just say you'll accept the
election results Trump didn't do it he
said I have to see the election results
before I can tell you whether I would
accept them when you start to hear about
the paramilitaries showing up in
Portland we have to remember that a
portion of this man's followers are more
than willing summer eager to get out
there and commit physical violence on
the streets in the name of Donald Trump
Trump has shown us that if we try to
predict how far he will go
we're always wrong he's always willing
to go further than whatever our
predictions are at any point in time and
the more cornered he gets and that's
what I believe he increasingly is right
now the more outrageous and belligerent
his behavior is going to get
I wonder what stories there are to be
told which maybe we will hear someday
about the things Trump almost did during
this administration and someone was just
barely able to but was able to stop him
from doing it you know the stories about
the things he did are bad enough there
must be just a treasure trove of
nightmares about the things he almost
did that someone stopped him from doing
and the next three plus months three
three months and a few weeks up until
the election are likely to be the most
dangerous
because of the desperation and the
feeling cornered and the cognitive stuff
is increasingly taking center stage and
I want to talk about that a little bit
next so the self-inflicted damage for
Donald Trump continues to be done the
doctor who developed the Montreal
cognitive assessment that's the
so-called test that Trump took in claims
he aced the doctor that created that
test has come out and said listen this
is supposed to be an easy test it's
really just meant to screen out
relatively serious cognitive decline and
remember that this is now relevant again
because in Donald Trump's bizarre
interview with Fox News host Chris
Wallace over the weekend Trump talked
about how he a status
Joe Biden couldn't do well on the test
Trump said Trump said the last five
questions are really tough and at one
point when Chris Wallace said they're
not really tough Trump accused Chris
Wallace of being unable to answer some
of the questions
it was completely outrageous as far as a
thing to say but more importantly the
real story here is we're now hearing as
we hear from the doctor who developed
the test the story is that Trump found
some of the questions difficult that's
really the red flag here's a reminder of
what Donald Trump said before we get to
what the doctor has now said people who
is more competent who's got whose mind
is sounder idn't beats you in that well
I tell you what let's take a test let's
take a test right now let's go down Joe
and I will take a test let him take the
same test that I took incidentally I
took the test too when I heard that you
passed it yeah how did you well it's not
the hardest task no you see that's all
misrepresentation that's what it was on
the web so I'll misrepresentation
because yes the first few questions are
easy but I'll bet you couldn't even
answer the last five questions I'll bet
you couldn't they get very hard to last
right well one of them was cut back from
a hundred by seven and let me tell you
now you couldn't answer you couldn't
answer many of the questions I'd get you
the test I'd like to give it but I
guarantee you the Joe Biden could not
answer this question you and I answered
all 35 questions correct you so Trump
said the first few questions are easy
but I
you couldn't even answer the last five
questions they get very hard now it is
strange in this is a test again meant to
screen out relatively serious cognitive
decline it's weird but by saying Chris
Wallace couldn't answer the last five
questions he's essentially saying he
believes Chris Wallace is suffering from
cognitive decline now this entire
portion of the interview is crazy also
because the test doesn't have thirty
five questions although it's based on a
maximum score of 30 points it doesn't
have thirty five questions and that's
sort of a weird thing for Trump to say
it is also crazy for Trump to say Chris
Wallace couldn't get the questions right
but now we have heard from dr. Ziad
Nasra Dean who developed this test and
dr. Nasser Dean is now speaking out and
saying listen you know this to this talk
about tough questions doesn't make any
sense this test is supposed to be really
easy for anyone who's not cognitively
impaired Trump talked about acing the
test like it's some kind of an
accomplishment when he spoke to Hannity
I believe it was last week remember this
one he didn't mean that because he
hasn't taken any cognitive test because
he couldn't pass once I actually took
one when I very recently when I when I
was you know the radical left was saying
is you all there is you all there and I
proved that was all there because I
asked it is the test and he should take
the same exact test the very standard
test I took took it at Walter Reed
Medical Center in front of doctors and
they were very surprised they said
that's an unbelievable thing rarely does
anybody do what you just did but he
should take that same test but now he
has been totally taken over aced the
test I mean this is ridiculous and dr. Z
odd Nasrudin said to MarketWatch that
quote this is not an IQ test or the
level of how a person is extremely
skilled or not the test is supposed to
help physicians detect early signs of
Alzheimer's and it became very popular
because it was a short test and very
sensitive for early impairment the
normal score according to dr. nas
routine is 27 out of 30
the toughest part is being given five
words and then being asked to recall
them after five minutes and then I
believe it's like after 10 minutes and
when you're in the middle of taking a
test this is the point that part is
sometimes the one that's tougher for
people even not suffering from cognitive
impairment but beyond that this is an
easy test where the normal score is
almost perfect the test cannot determine
if somebody is smart the test cannot
determine if somebody has a high level
of ability and when Trump said you know
doctors were shocked they had never seen
someone do what I did on this test it's
outrageous and it's laughable so the big
takeaways here are Trump said that the
questions get tough at the end that's
not true that's a concern number two
Trump said he recently took it we've not
been told that Trump took this test
since 2018 as far as we knew Trump took
the Montreal cognitive assessment in
2018 so if Trump was again tested
recently it would be not worth knowing
why where and what the circumstances
were because that's not actually been
revealed and number two again Trump
talks about 35 questions in the last few
are hard if he's talking about this test
that's a real problem if he was given
some other test then that would also be
important for the public to know and
then lastly maybe most importantly Trump
doesn't understand the nature of this
test like when he talks about acing it
and impressing doctors this is a test
where unless you're suffering from
cognitive decline you do really well on
it it's not that doctors would go wow
wow you really did it you know it turns
out that that that you're not actually
suffering from cognitive decline we're
so impressed with you mr. president
that's weird
and that's another question now the
other thing is people don't even
typically take this test unless there's
a question about their cognitive ability
now maybe because of all of the things
swirling around Trump Trump looked for a
test to take but it also shouldn't be
ignored that in normal circumstances
this is a test that a physician would
suggest if they have some reason to
think it's
important to screen out cognitive
decline who knows every aspect of this
just stinks to high heaven and as usual
Trump's discussions of the test only
raised more questions how many questions
are on it why did Trump find them tough
which test did he take who administered
it when did he take it why hasn't it
been mentioned or is he talking about
2018 I don't know that we're going to
get answers to these questions but the
important thing is we don't really need
any answers to these questions to know
he has to be voted out in just over
three months that part is clear and
that's what's making this increasingly
simple for more and more voters at least
the ones that I'm hearing from every day
let me know what you think I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman also remember to get
the daily audio podcast on your favorite
podcasting app whether it's stitcher
iTunes Google Play Pandora Spotify we're
on all of them get that daily podcast
every single day usually around three
third is when it's out the david pakman
show at david pakman.com
[Music]
the David Pakman show
depends on your support and the easiest
way is through membership which includes
the world-famous bonus show as well as
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show just for members sign up
today at join pakman.com coupon code
saves you 40% vote soon 18 the david
pakman show at david pakman.com today's
we members of the day are david wealthy
and edna Warneke David and Edna thank
you so much for your support also a big
THANK YOU to rod gratz who has been a
member for almost five years and is
today's longtime sustaining member of
the day thanks rod very much appreciate
grab yourselves a membership at join
pakman.com you'll get all of the great
member benefits the commercial free
audio and video streams of the show as
well as the daily world-famous bonus
show and so so much more join pakman.com
is the place to sign up so yesterday I
didn't have a chance to get to this but
I do want to play this clip for you
Donald Trump has launched yet another
attack on elements of plumbing including
showerheads and dishwashers and this has
been a really bizarre obsession for
Donald Trump here he is a few days ago
talking about I guess how Democrats
don't want you to have reasonable water
pressure of Democrats I guess as far as
Trumpkin it Trump is concerned want very
betta showers whereas Trump wants
powerful alpha showers with high water
pressure or something see if you can
understand what Trump is talking about
here pace is lower than that we're
bringing back consumer choice and home
appliances so that you can buy washers
and dryers shower heads and faucets so
shower heads you take a shower the water
doesn't come out you want to wash your
hands the waters as they come out so
what do you do you just stand there
longer you take a shower longer because
my hair I don't know about you but it
has to be perfect
perfect dishwashers you didn't have any
water so you the people that do the
dishes you press it and it goes again
and you do it again and again so you
might as well give them the water
because you'll end up using less water
so we made it so dishwashers now have a
lot more water and in many places in
most places of the country water is not
a problem they don't know what to do
with it it's called rain they don't have
a problem and old-fashioned incandescent
lightbulbs I brought them back I brought
them back they have two nice qualities
they're cheaper and they're better they
look better they make you look so much
better that's important to all of us but
they're better and much cheaper and they
were mandated out legislated out and we
brought them back and they're selling
like hotcakes so this is like a
completely outrageous rant I mean these
are truly the rantings of a madman it's
meaningless nonsense this is the type of
stuff where you know you see someone in
the subway yelling about this stuff you
probably call crisis services and say
somebody seems to be having a mental
health incident right now and these are
the things that mike pence sits in the
front row and nods along as if this is
normal to hear from a President of the
United States and this is not the only
time that Donald Trump did something
like this back in December fuels like
years ago but it was December before we
at least knew that coronavirus was in
the United States Trump ranted about
light bulbs and remember him saying
people are flushing toilets 10 or 15
times companies are very happy about
that
but together we're defending the
American workers we're using common
sense we have a situation where we're
looking very strongly at sinks and
showers and other elements of bathrooms
where you turn the faucet on in areas
where there's tremendous amounts of
water where the water rushes out to see
because you could never have
and you don't get any more do you turn
on the faucet you don't get any water
they take a shower and water comes
dripping out just clipping out very
quietly tripping out people are flushing
toilets 10 times 15 times as opposed to
once they end up using more water so EPA
is looking at that very strongly and my
suggestion you go into a new building or
new house or new home and they have
standards only you don't get water you
can't you can't wash your hands
practically this whole little water
comes out of the faucet and the end
result is you leave the faucet on and it
takes you much longer to wash your hands
you end up using the same amount of
water so we're looking at very seriously
and opening up the standard and there
may be some areas where we'll go the
other route desert areas but for the
most part you have many states where
they have so much water that it comes
down as cold rain it's really weird like
what is Trump doing in the bathroom that
he's flushing a toilet 10 or 15 times
that's really strange and this is about
something right and and it's actually
about a few things first is this
obsession Trump has not just with toilet
flushing but rolling back regulations
and the idea that the right has wanted
to frame up for a long time is there's
so much regulation everybody is
overburdened by regulations businesses
construction companies consumers that
this bird and back-breaking burden of
government regulation from Obama of
course there's you know the water
pressure is too low you can't wash
dishes you can't shower you can't
properly use the toilet apparently and
so they want to frame regulation happy
Democrats under the obama-biden
administration is passing too many
regulations and Trump is unburdening us
by cancelling those regulations now this
is of course completely crazy like
everything's fine water pressure is fine
dishwashers are working fine
everything's fine here in Boston in
Massachusetts I should say
we have some of the strictest building
code when it comes to efficiency and
appliances I run my dishwasher one time
it's a beautiful thing I flush my toilet
one time it's fantastic I turn on a
light bulb it's a you know CFL and I get
all the light I need I'm able to read my
books I'm able to read my magazines all
of this different stuff everything's
working fine and now then we have some
of the strictest building code in the
country the sad thing is Trump is
actually sort of tiptoeing around an
issue I would love to see a president
make their issue water quality much of
America has disastrous water quality in
some parts of the country you can't
drink the tap water in some parts of the
country you can but it's pretty vile
Flint Michigan obviously the situation
is worse than that and I would love it
if we had a president who said water
quality is going to be my issue this is
a serious issue you read about water
quality at a global level you find out
that there are so many deaths just from
lack of water that that that is safe you
have you know adults and children dying
from water quality related issues
parasitic infections diarrhea etc if we
had a president
listen there's so many things the
president can focus on that's the truth
if a president said I'm gonna do all of
these different things but one thing
that's not getting enough attention is
water quality in the United States it's
an issue of civil rights it's an it's an
issue of economics it's an issue of
class and globally my goal is to reduce
by half the number of people that are
getting sick and dying because of lack
of access to just safe drinking water
that would be such a material
improvement that a determined American
president as you know the so-called
leader of the free world most of the
time could do and Trump is talking about
water but he's talking about flushing
toilets 15 times and I guess low-flow
water heads or something like that Trump
really just making not make making
little sense during this event in
general here as Trump saying that there
will soon be announcements of things
that nobody thought possible or had
even conceived of so we have many
exciting things that we'll be announcing
over the next eight weeks I would say
things that nobody has even contemplated
thought about thought possible and
things that we're going to get done and
we have gotten done we started in most
cases but it's going to be a very
exciting eight weeks a eight weeks like
I prep I think Mike we can honestly say
nobody's ever going to see eight weeks
like we're gonna have yet they're going
to announce things that no one has even
contemplated crystal clear right so
something is very wrong here I don't
know whether I would say the wheel is
spinning but the hamster is dead I don't
know if I would say because we're
talking about lighting and showerheads
the lights are on but nobody's home I
don't know exactly what the right phrase
is but this is truly a man disconnected
from reality and I keep going back to 36
38 39 percent of the country supports
this there's a there's there's people
out there who see this and they say yeah
that's what I'm voting for
I'm voting for this the guy ranting
about light bulbs and flushing toilets
millions tens of millions of people will
be voting for what you just saw in
November for another four years of that
and as I've said before that's a scary
the trumpets are scary as Trump and the
reality is we will we will have trumpism
for longer than Donald Trump is in
office whether Trump leaves in January
or January of 2025 either way trumpism
will outlast Trump and that's going to
be a real problem we have to deal with
in this country for a long time going
forward here is a short venture into the
failed ideas that are floating around to
fight coronavirus Louisiana is a state
that is really suffering with
coronavirus Louisiana has the fourth
most cases per capita Louisiana has the
seventh most deaths per capita but most
importantly the disease is quickly
returning to Louisiana we're from early
June through yesterday cases have gone
higher and higher Louisiana has more
people actively infected today
than at any previous point during the
pandemic so what is Louisiana Governor
John bel Edwards do well he obviously
calls for three days of prayer and
fasting
now bel Edwards is a Democrat by the way
he says pastors reached out to him and
said you know you should maybe support
fasting and prayer to deal with the
virus so he's going to be calling for it
statewide take a look at this I do want
to let you all know that every couple
three weeks I have a the opportunity to
have a conference call with hundreds of
pastors across the state of Louisiana
and last week we had such a call and
received a request and I'm happy to
honor today and and it's I know it's a
little bit unusual but but I think it's
it's something that's it's important at
least for me and those people on the
call and many other Louisianans so I'm
going to call for three days of fasting
in prayer for our state for July 20th
through the 22nd so that's the the 20th
the 21st to 22nd this will be the
spiritual diet and exercise that I as a
Catholic Christian believes very
important anyway so we'll be doing lunch
fasting for those three days and and
certainly praying as well praying for
the people of Louisiana praying for
those who were sick praying for those
who care for those who were sick and
certainly praying for the families of
those who have passed on you know he he
is right when he says it's unusual that
started yesterday by the way July 20th
the fasting and prayer supposed to be
yesterday today and tomorrow now as he
Mont Mehta said hemant he Mont Mehta
said in a blog post
what bel edwards does in his spare time
is really his business but what pastors
want him to do should be irrelevant from
the standpoint of public announcements
as the secular governor of the state of
Louisiana now I don't mean personally a
religious I mean that the governorship
itself should be secular
separated from religion there's no
reason to tell people of the state to do
a religious ritual to fight a virus we
know what he should be calling for we
know what needs to be done everybody
should be wearing a mask which he did
say in his defense no large group
gatherings mostly stay home
certainly no indoor dining we know what
to do and the mask part he did say but
he's calling for prayer and fasting and
you know some people are defending this
by saying he said this is it
nondenominational right skip lunch and
and pray regardless of your denomination
what about people who aren't religious
this is still a government actor who is
supposed to be separate from the church
establishing a religious act
I mean prayer is a religious act over
non-religion and it's another example of
of this you know we've tried nothing and
we're out of ideas I mean he's already
going to pray or and fasting and it's a
Democratic governor not a Republican
this is not about political party for me
mostly this type of stuff is in the
Republican Party but here's an example
of it from the Democratic side this is
certainly a conservative Democrat don't
be confused but still this is a Democrat
and it reminds me of the situation in
Mississippi actually we've talked about
Mississippi Mississippi is tragically
suffering and has been for decades in
the United States and yet they're
talking and doing nonsense in
Mississippi it was how can we block
black voters from from voting or how can
we make sure that more real
Mississippians register because the
blacks are really registering to vote
meanwhile Mississippi is almost dead
last
or dead last in health care education
etc etc Louisiana is one of the most
ravaged states by most indicators
Louisiana's 45th and healthcare 48th and
education 49th in economic growth
48th and infrastructure 50th in dealing
with climate change it's a disaster in
Louisiana and then you look over and how
are they dealing with coronavirus well
the governor suggests skipping lunch and
praying now so
one wrote to me something that that is
interesting which is could this be
indirectly brilliant in other words bel
Edwards could be appealing to
religiosity by saying fast during lunch
lunch is when a lot of folks go out
especially if they're working maybe by
saying skip lunch
he's keeping people out of restaurants
and it's actually going to stop the
spread I don't know it's an interesting
question it's certainly the most
charitable interpretation of fast and
pray to stop the virus but that's not
really what what this is about this is
not about reverse engineering some way
in which a call for fasting and prayer
might connect to better health outcomes
with coronavirus this is a governor a
public elected official he has no place
suggesting religious prayer and fasting
on the say-so of Christian pastors as a
solution for a public health crisis and
again look at how poorly things are
going in Louisiana we have to ask
whether these things are connected we're
gonna have more about this on the David
Pakman show
Instagram page make sure you are
following us there at david pakman show
and while you're on your Instagram app
follow me at David Pakman we'll take a
quick break we do have tragic news to
discuss coming up after the interview
and I hope you'll be with me at the end
of the show
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon where you can pledge as little
as one dollar per month or as much as
you want at patreon.com slash david
pakman show great perks and benefits as
well read about him welcome back to the
David Pakman show it's great to welcome
to the program today Alex Vitaly who's a
professor of sociology at Brooklyn
College and also author of the book the
end of policing it's so great to have
you on Alex my pleasure Dave so this is
extremely timely and there's so many
different things I want to ask about
you've been studying this issue of
different policing practices and
techniques you've looked at
militarization of law enforcement the
expansion of the role of police over the
last 40 years and right now one of the
big discussions that's happening in
light of the George Floyd protests and
what is this is not my opinion but
according to polling not a particularly
good handling of policing and race
relations by the current President there
are discussions about what should happen
with police big picture so can you look
just to give us your 30,000 foot
overview as someone who's been following
this for a long time the claims that are
now being made are not new to you what
do you think is that the crux of the
debate that's happening now well I think
that following the the police killing of
Mike Brown in Ferguson and Eric garner
in New York and so many others the Obama
administration a lot of big city mayor
said look we're gonna fix policing with
a set of kind of procedural reforms
we're going to give them body cameras
and implicit bias training and
de-escalation training and things are
going to get better and things have not
gotten better you know the the situation
out on the streets remains very
problematic and people are fed up with
what they feel are these kinds of
simplistic solutions and so what
happening now is a demand to rethink why
we're using the police in all the
different ways that we're using them are
they really the right people to respond
to mental health emergencies or really
are they the right people to deal with
school discipline issues and and a whole
host of issues like that so one of the
things that sometimes I think makes
these conversations difficult in terms
of being productive is that the
conversations sometimes exist imagining
a different world than the one that
actually exists so like as an example
sometimes we hear there are countries in
Europe where the default is not that
police carry firearms there's a team
that has the firearms and sometimes the
firearms are left in the in the police
cars but as a rule the police aren't
walking around with firearms wouldn't
that be something to look at now that
sounds very interesting to me one key
difference is those countries don't have
the amount of armed civilians that the
United States has so is that a
reasonable example of how we need to be
dealing with things as they are as our
starting point rather than things as we
would wish them to be well absolutely I
mean this is an incredibly practical
movement that that is about turning
people out to City Council budget
hearings and lobbying City Council
members you know and yes a lot of it is
motivated by a kind of long-range desire
a kind of aspirational vision about
getting to this better world where guns
are not something that people are
walking around with as a general case
but I think everyone in this movement
understands that's not the world we live
in right now and that this is about a
process of creating safer communities by
dialing back both problems in the
communities and our over-reliance on
policing I want to get into the ideas
that are very at a superficial level
called either abolish or defund of
police now I did a piece about this a
couple of weeks ago my thought was there
are sources of funding that should
arguably be pared down fund
used for militarization for example
funding used for certain types of
weapons or equipment that really don't
have a place on streets but are more for
a battlefield on the other hand I'm
aware of circumstances where pulling
money may not actually help in the sense
that we may have a police department
that's already understaffed and
understaffed police department is likely
to go after the lowest hanging fruit as
they see it which is let's send our
limited police officers to the places
that we currently believe have more
crime of course more police officers in
one neighborhood are going to find more
crime in that neighborhood and it sort
of perpetuates the problems we're
actually trying to solve so my instinct
is that defund maybe not precise enough
in terms of a starting point but I'm
curious to hear what you think so you
know defund was not defund the police
was not really a term that was in wide
use before the current outbreak of
protests what was happening in dozens of
cities across the country were very
coherent campaigns about creating new
public safety initiatives that people in
those communities thought would actually
make them safer than just relying on
police and what what they would hear
from local politicians was well there's
no money to do that and they were saying
yeah but look every year you've
increased the police budget by 5% 7%
they've got all this new money for all
these tricked-out tanks and and
surveillance equipment and also some of
what the police are doing is actually
counterproductive we think it's actually
harmful and destabilizing so it's about
really identifying specific evidence
driven interventions to address specific
public safety problems that allow us to
dial back our reliance on policing which
has become this tool that's just being
used to address everything what are the
best examples of where that has worked
without as as there are some who just
oppose any reconsideration of how or
when police are deployed under the guise
that
there will be more crime it will be more
dangerous the public will be unprotected
what what counterpoints do we have where
these initiatives have worked sure well
I think it's become pretty obvious to
people that police should not really be
in the mental health business that
between a quarter and a half of all
people killed by police in the United
States are having a mental health crisis
and often the police play a
destabilizing and escalating role in
those conflicts and and those two crisis
situations and so that's why Albuquerque
and Milwaukee and Los Angeles and a
whole host of cities are now talking
concretely about putting in place
24-hour crisis intervention capacities
that would allow them to get the police
out of that business and a lot of them
are looking at a model being used in
Oregon called cahoots that's run by a
non-profit clinic that provides exactly
this kind of 24-hour crisis response
capacity for mental health calls
homeless people in distress someone
having a drug overdose or some other
drug related
you know low-level crisis and the folks
in Oregon are extremely happy with the
outcome of this approach and I think
we're gonna see a lot more cities adopt
it now as a purely logistical question
very often now it's not only police that
show up but it's also firefighters with
a big firetruck and that that can
sometimes be more aggravating to a
situation than less in these situations
where you have mental health workers
that are responding is that mental
health workers and fire or is it just
the mental health workers well there
might be a need for an EMS response if
the if the situation you know
potentially involved someone who might
need medication or might need to be
hospitalized and there is a lot of talk
about these Co response models where
police would also respond with these
teams but the evidence on that is really
thin that that the police presence is
not really adding value to those
encounters there may be situations where
a mental health team needs a backup at
some point
but having the police there from the
beginning of those interactions much
less a fire truck that's generally not
helpful though I would say that for
someone having a crisis it's precisely
the fact that an armed police officer
who is quite likely to arrest them or
compel them to go to a hospital that's
what often makes these encounters
dangerous in the first place and so when
we take that police response out of the
mix the chances of things going really
south is greatly reduced when it comes
to police training and when it comes to
police training let's let's open the
question there my instinct typically is
that workers are in a position of
disadvantage in many relationships with
employers and I'm supportive of
unionization and collective bargaining
etc there is a case to be made that some
elements that might really improve
policing like for example a national
database of bad actors if you concede
that most police individually are not
problematic but that a lot of the
incidents are happening from a
relatively small number of officers some
kind of national bad actor database
where police departments are required to
report to it but also new police
departments would be required to confer
with the database to see if the person
they're looking at hiring is is on the
database that seems to me like it would
be very powerful in eliminating the
relatively small percentage of bad
actors responsible for a lot of the bad
acts that's something I can't imagine
unions would ever go for what's your
sense of something like that and how
that should be navigated well I do think
that that a national database would be
useful and and support that and and
there's interestingly some bipartisan
support for it we've seen police unions
may not be as quick to object to that
across the board as you might imagine
because I think in this moment of crisis
there's a little bit more openness among
police leaders and police union leaders
to try to do something about that small
percentage of officers who generate the
most complaints and and who
or are fired for clearly just reasons of
course this is not going to solve all
the problems with policing right there's
a lot of ways in which perfectly lawful
procedurally proper policing can still
cause harms because we shouldn't be
using police in that situation in the
first place what's the lowest hanging
fruit in general in terms of the things
that could be done most quickly and
easily that would have the greatest
impact well in addition to the mental
health example we discussed earlier I
think there's a lot of efforts underway
to remove police from schools I think
this was a really misguided idea driven
by some real misinformation about the
nature of the problem in Europe they
think we're crazy they would never do
this we need to get police out of the
mental health I'm sorry out of the
homelessness business responding to
homeless people who are clearly in
distress I think we need a rethink about
the war on drugs that's that's a bigger
lift but I think that we've got so much
evidence that shows that turning that
problem over to police is just such a
bad idea what about the issue of police
immunity which is now being brought up
that there that the I guess generally
speaking the idea that it's too easy for
officers not to be held accountable in a
particular way that some in the public
would like to see because of immunity I
mean that that's certainly not
low-hanging fruit in the sense that that
would be a huge undertaking to look at
that but how much of a priority do you
believe it should be well I don't think
it should be a huge priority I'm not
against it but I think there's a lot of
fantasy thinking that this is going to
be some kind of cure-all and again it
assumes that all the problems with
policing are about these small number of
videotaped horrible incidents and the
problems of policing are also about the
other 10 million arrests they make every
year many of them for things that just
shouldn't be dealt with through policing
and so getting rid of qi is not going to
affect that in any meaningful way and I
also think the political lifts as you
mentioned is going to be so hard on that
that it would be better to focus on
creating these alternative
community-based public safety
initiatives and trying to focus on that
instead when it comes to what some call
over criminalization the fact that there
are activities which are criminalized
and that's of course a societal choice
to make you mentioned the war on drugs
which certainly would would be an
example of that generally but outside of
the war on drugs do you think over
criminalization is a problem and what's
what specific areas would you want to
look at first yeah I think it is a major
problem research by the Vera Institute
of Justice showed that there are
approximately 10 million arrests a year
in the United States and the vast
majority of them are for very low-level
offenses that are really tied to the
broken windows philosophy of policing
which is about criminalizing and
micromanaging the behavior of already
very vulnerable communities and it's a
way of turning problems of poverty and
joblessness and lack of health care into
criminal justice problems but but that
system doesn't have the tools that are
going to help solve people's addiction
problems mental health problems
homelessness problems joblessness
problems and that's really what we've
seen over the last 40 years is the
turning of all these social and economic
problems into criminal justice problems
and that's why the problem is so much
bigger than just a few officers with an
abusive track record isn't that by
design in some sense and now I feel like
there is it certainly a political split
where there is a political contingent in
the United States that you know it's the
same folks who they say they're against
abortion and you show them a study that
says great we know exactly how to
prevent abortion prevent unwanted
pregnancy here's how you do it now what
we don't we don't like those things and
it's about if you have unprotected sex
you should have to deal with the
consequences because that's sort of
what's right and moral in the same ways
we've seen it's cheaper to house and
give health insurance to the homeless
than it is to absorb the social costs of
them being on the street
now it doesn't fit into the morality I
feel like there's something similar in
what you're describing and an obstacle
to me seems the political side of it I
think that's exactly right that we've
turned a lot of what a really public
health and and political and economic
problems into questions of morality and
that that fits with a kind of broader
ideology that says that you know the
problems of crime and disorder are the
result of individual and group moral
failure that will only respond to
punitive interventions and what this
does is it lets politicians off the hook
for actually addressing things like
housing market failures and labor market
failures and discrimination and
education and employment and so they
don't have to take responsibility for
that anymore because the problem is
those people and they're bad morality
and I I think one really powerful
example you'll be interested in is
operation relentless pursuit which is
the Trump administration's big new tough
on crime initiative where they're going
to flood seven US cities with federal
agents and money for local police to get
Trump's favorite bugaboos you know the
drug cartels and the gang bangers yeah
and what this is about is saying that
the problems of Detroit and Cleveland
and Memphis and Baltimore are not a
failed federal policy on housing jobs
health insurance no it's the gangbangers
it's the drug cartels and this is
exactly the process that we have to
interrupt we've been speaking with alex
vitality who's professor of sociology at
brooklyn college the book is the end of
policing Alex I really appreciate your
time and your insights my pleasure Dave
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]
whether you're looking for david pakman
show coffee for your Chemex or French
press or a David Pakman show t-shirt
it's all available on our website
shipping to anywhere in the world at
david pakman.com slash gear
don't miss the bumper stickers to david
pakman.com forward slash gear the david
pakman show at david pakman.com
some truly tragic I mean just
unconscionably tragic news to report to
you from the progressive media community
today as I know many of you have already
heard the host of the Michael Brooks
show Michael Brooks has suddenly passed
away and yesterday in the early
afternoon some of the progressive hosts
were in touch as we started to learn of
what had happened and initially I just
sort of assumed that this was wrong I
was misinformed but ultimately of course
the news was made public and indeed
Michael Brooks passed away suddenly
Michael Brooks I will tell you a little
bit about how I met Michael Brooks but
Michael had been working for some years
as a sort of co-host and producer for
sam cedars majority report had
ultimately launched his own program the
Michael Brooks show which was doing
really well
regular guests on different programs and
someone that I've known for for nearly a
decade and indeed we learned in the
afternoon in a statement from the
majority report it is with a heavy heart
that we announced the unexpected passing
of Michael Brooks a son brother friend
and true comrades so many due to a
sudden medical condition you can check
out the entire statement which talks
about some of Michael's accomplishments
and essentially points out that the way
to honor Michael is to keep doing the
activism work pointing out that his
family will release a statement in the
near future about how they plan to keep
his work alive and it you know I I spoke
to so many other progressive hosts
yesterday many of us almost exactly the
same age as Michael and it just sort of
like doesn't make sense that's that it's
it's confusing there's no real other way
to say it it it takes a while for it to
even become a reality
and I first met Michael about ten years
ago I actually don't remember this was
when I lived in Northampton
Massachusetts and so did Michael and I
don't remember if it was a frequent
david pakman show guest bill scher or
another friend of ours michael cusack
who said hey I know this guy Michael
Brooks he's big into politics he does
some writing he's interested in getting
involved in what you're doing and I
remember meeting with Michael at this
great cafe the roost in Northampton
Massachusetts he had tea of course in
typical Michael Brooks fashion I don't
remember what I had but we talked for
hours and we decided he would come up to
my studio and record some clips these
clips are still on the David Pakman show
YouTube channel if you go back in the
archives and then eventually we got to
talking about opportunities and he had
talked about you know I would move I
don't know I'd look at New York and so I
made an introduction I said to Sam cedar
I know you're always sort of in the mix
looking for who are good people that
might be able to work with you this
guy's done some clips with me and I
think you might be interested in talking
to him and of course the rest is history
they met Sam hired Michael Michael
became a fixture on the majority report
and ultimately launched his own program
and it is just such a loss to the
community it's a loss in terms of the
person of Michael it's a loss in terms
of the political perspective which as
many people know Michael and I are not
exactly aligned in terms of we're on the
Left we are and that's okay and the
truth is since I moved out of New York
I've been much less in touch with
Michael and and obviously you know how
many how many millions of times has it
happened that you fall out of touch with
someone and then you lose the
opportunity to get back in touch with
them which is exactly what what happened
now in in a tragic sense quite frankly
so I don't know what what happens now I
mean it's sort of like this is news that
is only hours old I've been in touch
with you know Kyle kolinsky and our
friends over at Ring of Fire and of
course Sam and Benjamin Dixon and I
you know our friends ana kasparian and
no miki const all all who have said
things about this and it there's just no
real easy way to synthesize something so
sad and so unexpected
other than to know that Michael would
want our activism to continue Michael
would want all of us to keep trying to
push society in the right direction
because if we lose he never wanted
anybody to lose sight of that and
whether you call it a big picture
mentality or a whole world mentality or
whatever and I think the most the the
most relevant thing for me from this
horrible statement because of the tragic
news that that it communicates is this
line at the end about we will honor
Michael by treating all humans with
respect and dignity I think that that is
the really important thing here where
this is just bad I mean listen 2020 has
been pretty horrible it in in a lot of
ways the virus so many people I know
with personal tragedy now we're adding
this it's it's not been the best year so
far um but I think what we can all it's
hard to be confident in anything when
something like this happens but what we
can all be confident in is that the
right thing is always to advocate for
improving the world and that's what
Michael sought to do through his program
that's what my instinct is we all seek
to do with our programs will sometimes
disagree about the exact right way to do
it but the point is we're all in this
together and at a more personal level
you know the importance of remaining in
touch and together not just with
individuals and and obviously you know
having lost touch with Michael over the
last couple of years that's an
individual thing that I can say but also
the importance of remaining together in
the progressive community and not
missing the forest for the trees which
sometimes happens and if this has the
silver lining in the midst of just
unspeakable shocking tragedy of
reminding us of that and that a lot of
those day-to-day disagreements that we
may have and conflicts that we may have
they really mean nothing in the end that
there they are essentially meaningless
in the end and I think that that's
something that's very much on my mind as
we grieve the loss of of Michael Brooke
something we'll certainly be talking
more about in the future